Jennifer what is the difference between
young adult fiction versus non why a
fiction well young adult fiction is a
category it is not technically a genre
and it involves protagonists for the
most part that are ages 12 to 18 years
old the readership for a young adult is
traditionally teens but it has it has
exploded more adults or reading the
category so over 50% of the readers of
young adult fiction are now technically
adults so that's basically what
distinguishes it will be teen characters
teen characters okay and in terms of
what happens in the story the arc how
does it differ from adult readership I
don't know if the character arts differ
so much I mean they're basically the
same kind of stories that everyone's
telling technically a lot of them maybe
are coming-of-age stories and there's
because we're dealing with that time in
a character's life which is you know
there are teen years but right now the
genre has become so expansive that it's
really tackling lots of hearted hitting
issues things like suicide things like
drug use even things like abortion or
being tackled so it's really kind of
expanded the kind of subject matter I
tend to write genre which is science
fiction so you do see a lot of science
fiction fantasy kind of writing and I
think that it's what kind of more fun
because teen readers have huge
imaginations and they love reading that
kind of stuff now what attracts you to
science fiction versus more of let's say
a personal you know a like an inner
personal story yeah like contemporary
yeah actually um contemporary is hugely
popular that's probably the most popular
thing happening and young adult right
now and the first book I ever wrote was
actually an adult contemporary novel
which did not sell it did go on
submission that is a very typical story
you'll hear from most authors most
authors don't sell their first book it
did a lot of work for me it landed me a
huge agent and I learned a lot writing
it but my heart and my passion has
always been in John were writing I'm a
huge love the Rings fan I love Star Wars
movies growing up I read a lot of
science fiction
like Edgar Rice Burroughs Hoover at
Tarzan but I'm obsessed with his Mars
books his John Carter series so once I
started writing it I just was like wow
how did I not start writing this from
the beginning I love it so much what I
love about science fiction in particular
is kind of this idea of where our world
might be going and really grounding it
in real science real details and really
looking at something that might be
predictive but also instructive about
you know some of the pitfalls we're
falling into a lot of my books do deal
with issues like weapons nuclear
proliferation like what could happen in
the future with that so allegorically
it's pretty fascinating so yeah that's
kind of what draws me to science fiction
we talk about the ways in which the
young adult audience differs from the
adult audience not just in terms of age
but also maybe in the outcome of the
story or is it the same thing um you
know the story outcome and I think I
mean honestly I think storytelling is
storytelling I mean I think that those
of us who are writing young adult are
really striving to tell stories that are
really captivating and interesting so I
don't know that there's a lot of
difference between them aside from the
preoccupation like you're not gonna see
a young adult story that's a lot about
you know long-term marriage let's you
know you might get it as terms of you
know parent characters and maybe
relationships but you know young adult I
think though is a little bit freeing
writing it because you know with adult
fiction you tend to get locked in to
certain you know audiences and I think
the readers are a little more jaded what
I love about meeting teen readers is
that they're not jaded they are so
enthusiastic when they love something
they love it with their whole heart and
they get so excited and there's nothing
like getting kids reading so that's sort
of the difference that I see and the
adults that are reading it they're
looking for something fun and something
escapist and something that reminds them
of that time in their life when they
were teenagers so the again that tends
to be less of like the jaded kind of oh
this is like some huge literary book
where like everyone hates each other and
they're all like a ball like not that
you couldn't write that but it tends to
be
genre where it's more fun to read I
think people are looking for something
that's enjoyable when these readers
approach you at book signings or
whatever are they approaching you from
the angle of enjoying the story and
feeling as if the characters are real or
are they aspiring why a authors as well
you know most of the people that come to
book festivals and book signings are
just avid readers like they're really
passionate about reading usually the
people that are turning up but these
events read voraciously so you're
talking people that consume large
quantities of books occasionally you get
parents that are dragging their kids
along but mostly its readers I will get
occasionally teens that are aspiring to
write and I do work with a mentoring
program where I mentor kids and teach
writing which I love and I always get
excited whenever I meet someone that's
interested in writing or inspired to
write a big thing that happens with
young adult readers is that they end up
writing fanfiction or at least that's a
lot of times their first foray into
writing which is hugely popular online
so fanfiction would be like Harry Potter
fanfiction is huge so that would be
writing stories about the Harry Potter
characters for fun really I mean that's
really the reason to do it and there are
quite a few fan fiction authors who've
gone on to huge success like the author
that wrote the Mortal Instruments series
she started out writing Harry Potter
fanfiction Yale James who wrote fifty
shades of gray that is famously that is
Twilight fan fiction so you see a lot of
that going on
you